[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no
[Music]
idea wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
welcome to the this is
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
everybody here for the interview
me too
what do you drive
i got the jet bike
they're ready to see you mr crew oh good
great
[Music]
here we go
distinguished villains
my name is crew
i feel like i'm talking too loud even
though our proximity doesn't require
this kind of volume
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain
yes i am pretty despicable you don't
want to cross me
come back when you've got something evil
to impress me
[Music]
i'll distract them
this is the biggest day of my life
this kid just stole something from the
world's villains in the world
time to strike
[Music]
are you pulling on my legs right now
otto where's the stone oh
no
pasta
[Music]
did you just trade my future
for a bedrock
oh i didn't mean to scare you now where
is groom
[Music]
say what i want 24 7 365.
i know it's a lot
but i don't got time to mess around
oh about that hustle am i right
[Music]
and nothing's gonna get in my way
[Music]
breakfast is ready
[Music]
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
[Applause]
oh look at me stay back this happened
already
what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk runs in our family
sick i've always wanted a tail i'm a
freak we love you mae you're our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotion yet will release the
panda abby hit me
[Music]
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get ripped up into a frenzy and panda
all over
but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
it's gonna be me
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad oh no i have a
total dad bod
um what is going on
huh
what's up
i'm
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo man
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
mosquito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
go okay
cabin pressurization is underway as we
prepare for ignition
flight recorders are on
t minus five
four
three
two
one
zero
we have not
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that all the children
to infinity
and
[Music]
baby i'm
[Music]
you got a minute oh what
when how did she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adorable
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too okay
so what are you doing here
i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good
[Music]
wake up buddy it is one o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
[Music]
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestruct dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
[Music]
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
just which is crazy i didn't even know
that was a thing but it's like a dog
water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k9g what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
hey you get over here
oh i know what it is you're afraid
because i'm the big bad wolf
the villain of every story
and this is the crew mr tarantula mr
shark mr piranha mr snake everyone copy
copy copy
we're the bad guys it's crime time baby
shark we need a distraction do i get to
improvise fine please be subtle
i'm having a baby
is there a doctor or perhaps several
security guards that could leave that
post and help me
we were never given a chance to be
anything more than criminals but these
are the cars we've been dealt so we
might as well play them
here let me help you are you okay ma'am
thank you dear you're such a good boy
wait what i'm the bad
guy
well good brother oh good yeah yeah
you ever wonder what it'd be like if the
world wasn't scared of us never gonna
happen guys we're going to go good
did you get hit on the head he wouldn't
have an image problem you need a
makeover
so
well there goes our street cred
i'm tired of being an outcast maybe i
don't want to be a what a bad guy you
can't have to choose between your
friends or the good life they're the
only friends i've ever had you have a
chance to write your own story what have
you got to lose i don't know my dignity
yeah well that ship has already sailed
so you're a tough guy
that is an animal testing that with
helpless guinea pigs i'll rescue them
you've never volunteered for anything
oh
come on snake open up relax these doors
are complicated
are you kidding me we're supposed to
save them not eat them well i'd say
they've gone to a better place
[Music]
it's time for us to move out and make
our mark on the world awesome
oh no
those ding-dongs went back to the lost
world oh and i thought i made bad
choices
the lost world
the world's most dangerous place
wait a minute can you repeat that
i had a marshmallow in my ear oh [ __ ]
crying out now
what brings you to here
we came here to live a life of adventure
like you
i'm starting to question our judgment
this is the perfect time to do it
it's time to get
back wild [ __ ] you like a superhero
i wouldn't use the term superhero
i mean i wouldn't stop you from using it
[Music]
i love family reunions
this is it amy moment of truth
remember might be keys to success don't
screw up
god
i can't watch
but i can't look away
[Applause]
[Music]
when your uncle upon and i went
searching for the hamster of darkness
what the
finding you
was the best thing
that ever happened to me i can't believe
we got to be seen with that freak
chicken here everybody laughs at me dad
would you expect he's mostly chicken no
he's mostly hair shaking sounds like
they're cheering for you chicken hair
chicken hair chicken
if i can bring back the hamster of
darkness everyone shall accept me
i'm okay
need a guide i'm meg
follow in my footsteps and you'll be
okay well that's too bad looks like
we'll have to head back
follow me
[Music]
to enter the temple one must pass the
three deadly
trials can't it ever be two trials
captain
i'm going down don't move
all of us are born with things that make
us different
[Music]
the only choice we have is recognize
that our differences are what makes us
special
here we go
oh please
you couldn't have brought the extra
large whip could you meg
how many flying hairs have you ever seen
you have wings don't you i can't fly you
can watch
can't fly
emergency at the chemical factory no
georgia girls aren't allowed to be fine
but i'm as brave as any boy
it's my dream it's my destiny
girls can't be firemen give me a break
[Music]
extra extra arsonist again
the firemen
go into the theaters
they don't come out
i need you to run the fire investigation
i'll need a team here's the plan i
joined dad's team egg crate for the
stomach muscles mango for the biceps
and for the mustache
[Music]
oh okay too much
shake what your mama gave you
what your mama gave up
are you one of the volunteers
do i
know you
let me introduce you the brains of your
operation ricardo
uh ginger driver fastest cabbie in
manhattan
who are you me uh i'm joe i'm fireman
joe slow down joe did you even check
this
the water pressure
we're going in
let's the show
seriously
it's funny
you remind me of my daughter really yeah
that is funny
yeah she wanted to be a fireman too
so why didn't you teach her what you're
teaching me she's my daughter i love her
and i worry about her every second of my
life
i catch the arsonist i'll have to change
the rules then i'll be the first fireman
woman the job is far too dangerous
maybe this is a sign that it's time you
follow your own dreams
i never gave up on mine
the mustache is very convincing it's my
dog's butt hair oh
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a little song full of danger
everywhere but don't you wear it all
that apostles owns the giants that's not
a problem for this boy he will find a
way
[Music]
they are his faithful friends that will
always keep him happy and safe
[Music]
[Music]
you